وهو تعليقا على الرفض الروسي للقرار قاده
المتحدث باسمي المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه
فادي العبد الله ان القرار ملزم رغم عدم
عضويه روسيا في نظام روما واضاف عبدالله
في اتصال خلال نشره سابقه ان اختصاص
المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه يشمل الانتهاكات
المرتكبه على الاراضي الاوكرانيه
وقبلت باختصاص المحكمه فيما يجري على
اراضيها الوضع مشابه لاي شخص يسافر الى
مكان ما ممكن ان يرتكب جريمه فهو يخضع فقط
لمحاكم بلده الاصلي وانما ايضا
للمحكمه في المرتبطه بالمكان الذي وقعت
فيه الجريمه فاذا اختصاص من المحكمه ليس
مرتبطا بعضويه روسيا وهي بالفعل ليست دوله
منضمه الى نظام ولكنه مرتبط
بالاعلاميين السابقين لدينا قدمتهما
اوكرانيا بقبول تطبيق اختصاص المحكمه
عليها وبالتالي على ما يجري سواء من
مواطنيها او على اراضيها